a lot's happened we haven't been here
for about a week and a half because of
uh
last week's vault which was absolutely
sick
with dustin poitier we had uh what do
you call it uh gary casper who crushed
it by the way the message he had against
communism was fascinating and then we
have billy being there talking about
data we had a uh who else i'm forgetting
phil spoke friend uh greg shearer
talking about private equity crushed it
phil absolutely crushed it and then uh
uh
uh you know thank you thousands of
people
thousand people we had a nice party at
the yacht then afterwards we had a nice
party at the house couple nights ago you
know the place was uh uh unreal but the
most common conversa people were there
to find out how to take their businesses
to the next level right that's right one
of the most common uh conversations that
everybody was talking about is how
afraid they were about freedom and
capitalism so cameras off there's no
cameras we're talking at the restaurant
hey pat what do you think about what's
going to happen with freedom what do you
think what's going to happen with the
capitalism what do you think what's
going to happen these are people from
around the world that are all having
the same types of conversations about
uh what we're going to be doing but gary
got up
and gary delivered a message he called
that putin he called that he called out
everybody with no
restriction he didn't hold anything back
so he ran an await against putin here's
a
the goat of chess you're talking about
the guy that played chess for what he
was number one for 250 something months
in a row i've never heard of anybody
being number one
255 months in a row that's over 21 years
where you're think about all the goats
of all time who has ever been first
place for 255 months in poker in tennis
in basketball in baseball i've never
heard of anybody now the
credit to chess players you can't get a
knee injury it's not gonna they're not
gonna get you now
right your elbow's out you know i got to
get some kind of a treatment but at the
same time the mental for fortitude to be
able to stay that uh but i love that
question you asked him by the way you
said like you talk about you can't have
a knee blow out but yeah you know sports
you know everything that's happening
with you but in chess how do you get it
up here yeah he did and his answer was
look at at some point after 20 years of
being doesn't matter anymore you just
get kind of bored yeah it doesn't matter
anyway i thought it was interesting and
i said so
politics any aspirations for politics
he's like no i don't do politics i don't
do politics i was on stage on stage so
when you don't do politics we had a good
conversation in the back would you share
that conversation uh the one in the back
yeah it was it was pretty easy i'll
share a part of it but i asked him i
said what are you doing right he said
what do you mean what am i doing i said
what are you doing i said what was this
all about he says i don't understand the
question i said you have a message that
the world needs to hear about right
you're a seven-year-old kid in
russia
under a communistic regime that becomes
a phenom
the entire time you think america is the
worst country in the world then you get
a flavor of capitalism at 13 years old
then you realize how amazing capitalism
is then you come back and you win for
your country you have one of a few
people who was able to make it because
chess in russia is seen as
you know it's like uh the weather yeah
now you got a message with all the mess
going on in the world then you want to
stay quiet he says well i tweet i i
write i said no that's not enough you
gotta do something so he says what do
you think we should do anyways he sent
you an email you guys are doing
something together in october yeah but
anyways it was uh it was good because
more and more you would be amazed how
many people around the world support
capitalism had a tweet that went out
today about the fact that um
you know why i love capitalism i said
here's a kid
uh uh uh valuetainment put it up what
was the messaging let me see if i have
it here
if you want to pull it up kai and then a
guy responds back and this is the one
messaging
that gets heat sometimes oh let me see
where this is kai if you pull it up
uh okay why i love capitalism it says
capitalism
allowed an immigrant like me with zero
generational wealth zero privileges and
a one point gpa till my dreams become a
reality the only privilege i need was
the fact that my parents sacrificed
everything to bring us to u.s right the
rest was on me
so then a guy responds back and he says
capitalism works
if you have capital to start off with
right if you have capital let's not be
able to read yeah exactly so this guy
responds back and he says capitalism
only works if you have capitalism to
start off with and i said not true
i started off with
zero no generational wealth that was a
99 cent store cashier mom went back to
iran because she ran out of money i
saved every penny i could at my jobs
instead of partying in order to one day
start a business others can do the same
there's this notion that
capitalism only benefits the rich
capitalism only benefits you know the
the few but at the end of the day it's
the greatest
economical system that allows anybody
with whatever skin color you have
whatever nationality whatever religion
we're at the event
you're having all these conversations
i cannot tell you how big of a muslim
population we had at the event yeah i
couldn't believe it a muslim capitalist
yeah wow we're at the event our friend
tamara
crying from stage emotional one girl got
up she was crying saying
as a muslim from azerbaijan i cannot
wait she says i'm willing to sacrifice
my own life to finish and end communism
this makes no sense there was one muslim
girl who
son says hey can i give you a hug she
says no i'm sorry we can't do that
she's that devout to her religion but
supports capitalism it doesn't matter
what educational level you were at what
part of the world what nationality it
looked like the united nations were
there
except they were there to support
capitalism it was a beautiful thing to
see
countries yeah twelve different
countries
one of our biggest audiences australia
they couldn't come out
one of our biggest we have italy that
was one of our biggest couldn't come out
germany so many different places
couldn't come out
there's a guy from germany that got
denied visa three times yeah and he got
in the fourth
he went to the embassy they told him no
he changed one guy he played again one
guy flew from i don't know what it was
uh uh no not only where it was from he
flew
he flew to one country then they sent
him back he flew to another country then
they sent him back then he flew to
istanbul to try to go from istanbul to
central america to come to us in
istanbul they hold him back he's about
to get on the flight they send him back
he wasn't able to make the event three
different ways he tried to come out i
mean it's a mess right now around the
world what's going on we got obviously a
lot of stories to cover it's good to be
back uh the update on biz dock biz doc
is doing very good yeah he's making a
lot of progress i'm happy for him uh it
was a very positive news yesterday he
was in icu with pneumonia but he's doing
better shout out to
yeah absolutely man everybody that's
been praying for praying for him or
meditating praying or meditating sending
positive thoughts sending positive
thoughts and vibes so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]